on a les photos de vous en 85 ou là
alors on va regarder gilles verdez par
exemple bernès voyons gilles verdez non
à la mairie jacques où il apprit
pouilles attend les visiteurs
hervé c'est ouf c'est la période baba
consistait à oui c'est vrai mais non
c'est vous dire tremblay avoue
d'ailleurs je pense ça vous dépanne
changée en orange était de julio
iglesias moi non je dirais qui tu es
beau tu es beau gosse alors facile alors
moi j'ai moi j'ai une photo de moi
en 85 voilà regarder lyon
oui bah ouais mignon gpat elle lâche
rien on a tellement
non mes cheveux légèrement plus plus
blond ouais c'est pourquoi ses vrais
cheveux blonds parce que 18 ans allez
merci beaucoup
en 85 cc de près c'est beaucoup de
choses
d'ailleurs tiens s'il y avait une
chanson d'annie cordy qui se tient chaud
cacao chaud cacao qui a fait polémique
en pole et mal à écouter jugement alors
c'est comment en tous les cas si sarah
cissé baril mais on va regarder le clip
de dépôt et regarder chaud cacao
[Musique]
ça
elle a cessé ses réponses étaient
champions pour les en discuter longtemps
bah oui on pourrait excuser ou alors
c'est comme les blagues faith alors
maintenant quand on voit gérard darmon
café othello l'émission parlez pas mal à
parler bien sûr le blackface c'est un
délit mais oui mais oui mais bien la
montée en charge de l'impression qu'on
régresse dans les temps changent je fais
attention à ce qu'on dit oui peut-être
mais pas les temps tout à l'air dans
l'émission est ce qu'on peut dire ou ne
pas dire
et des conséquences que cela peut avoir
d'ailleurs alors en 85 cia l'émission
quitte à perdre en 85 qui est vidéomaton
voire pas de signer sur wii sympa alors
c'est en fait les gens devenaient se
secoue se confie je crois que c'est ça
qui a inspiré les petites annonces
d'elie semoun est exactement et oui
regardez vidéomaton regardez je suis
célibataire
aussi j'aimerais rencontrer une fable
entre 30 et 40 ans libérée
n'ayant pas de trop de problèmes
exerçant une profession de préférence
non non on en a marre on cherche au
moins un travail un petit travail ça ne
suffirait un petit tuyau ça ne me
suffirait fameux neymar est dans la
merde on n'est pas des merdes ont fait
s'en sortir et on n'a aucune chance
c'est dégueulasse à le penser un petit
peu à nous à goli kéké pêches qui lui
revient
nous faisons du funk et du rap en arabe
et si éventuellement quelqu'un est
intéressé pour que lens produisent avec
lui symbole serait fort utile s'est
laissée dans cette de slap shot aidé
beaucoup faudrait recommencer
non c'est un authentique ans d'écart et
voile c'est la dure elle me croyez moi
vivons avec notre temps en 85 qui a un
événement évidemment que personne n'a
oublié c'est la création des restos du
coeur
absolument pas reconnu c'était à
l'ouverture du premier restaurant du
coeur seulement il avait lancé
d'ailleurs je crois chez michel drucker
oui dans les rendez vous du mois ayant
cherché sur europe 1 et sur europe 1
regardez c'est l'heure du grand
lancement pour les restos du coeur ça y
est les restaurants du coeur commence
dans la région du nord on va faire
aujourd'hui on va distribuer 4000 repas
c'est là où on a le plus gros effort
bordeaux évidemment toulouse amiens
marseille le havre lyon enfin voilà
dix-huit villes en france ont ouvertes
aujourd'hui ça va les gars sont un peu
froids c'est quoi ta télé
coluche lui-même s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement vingt bénévoles mais
aussi des entreprises et d'autres
associations sont venues apporter leur
aide
est ce que vous vous rappelez de ceux
qui ont participé aux premiers clips des
restos du coeur
il y avait nathalie baye michel drucker
et ruquier du montant évidemment jean
jacques goldman yves montand michel
platini
ah oui et oui chez nathalie baye et on
l'a dit déjà
mais voilà alors il y avait il y avait
un peu tout le monde les bases est du
coeur est d'ailleurs à l'époque j'ai
envie de dire que tout le monde à tous
les inconnus pouvait aider les restos du
coeur après c'est un peu un fait que
compliquer leur fermer en revanche je
savais qu'ils ont ouvert les restos du
coeur grâce à coluche et c'est avec un
tas de personnalités
mais les concerts ont eu lieu beaucoup
plus tard grâce à l'initiative de
jean-jacques goldman y avait eddy
mitchell johnny et véronique sanson et
et jean jacques goldman qui ont fait et
michel sardou absolument qu'on faisait
le tour de france au casting c'est comme
ça qu'il avait rencontré mois l'époque